[Music]
no other serial gives you
much vitamin b1 and mire
Warbeck happy and satisfied
[Music]
tickles your tongue it's hot
an Avenger in every Bowl
[Music]
food to me anyway is one of the great
pleasures in life I love it I'd love to
eat I like to fix big dinners for my
friends and have a good time and eat but
you don't have to eat things that are
bad for you in order to have things that
are succulent and tasty and wonderful if
you haven't tasted a lot of things in
their natural state you didn't run right
out and do it because it's great I mean
it's really fantastic and it's it's a
shame that so many people miss out on
that because of so-called convenience
foods the character of a food supply has
changed considerably in the past 25
years until 1950 we are essentially an
agricultural food supply that is the
situation where food was grown by the
farmer taken to the market boards
unchanged by the housewife and cooked
and prepared for a family since 1950 and
increasingly since 1960 we have
developed there or we have had pushed
onto us an industrial food supply that
is one where foods were more and more
processed and where instead of the food
has grown being sold the food was in a
sense mined an entirely new food
made from it
processing of food itself is not a new
idea but new methods of processing are
changing our eating habits with Factory
foods and bewildering numbers
many of the modern foods so-called
modern foods are not nearly as
nutritious as the old-fashioned fresh
fresh fruits and vegetables and other
products we got from the farm
many of these foods are high in sugar
high in salt in a number of cases
nutrients have been removed from the
foods and when you add this up the
nutritional content of the American diet
has actually deteriorated in recent
years things are getting worse not
better
[Music]
today so we can buy good food our diets
are worse than they were 10 years ago
too many of us have health problems
because we eat poorly too many non
nutritious foods too few vitamins and
minerals this bread that I'm making
right now is made with whole wheat flour
which is just a stone ground and honey
and milk and some added wheat germ so
you know it'll be a good bread I mean it
will not only taste really delicious but
it will be a really useful and good food
whereas white bread that you buy in the
store or white bread that you make
yourself out of refined you know white
flour that's had the wheat germ removed
and the bran removed is almost entirely
starch
as food is processed nutrients are
usually removed the milling of grain is
a glaring example most of the minerals
and vitamins and a weak kernel are on
the surface and the bran and outer
layers and in the growing center called
the wheat germ flour made from the
complete wheat kernel of wheat flour
contains these nutritious parts of the
wheat but most flour is ground further
to make white flour in making white
flour the wheat germ and bran are
removed and the major portions of many
minerals and vitamins are lost part of
the protein and most of the fiber are
also lost the bran and outer layers are
sold for cattle feed and our will
nourish pets gets the wheat germ
you
when a bread company makes white bread
they put back a few of the lost
nutrients
[Music]
they're advertising then tells us how
good the bread is for us because it is
enriched but they don't say is that
enriched bread contains only a few of
the original nutrients happily you don't
have to buy white bread most stores have
a variety of nutritious whole-grain
breads you're supposed to be more wheat
in a whole-wheat and bleached white
flour yeah but it's hard to have faith
and anything anymore but I by week we're
it is really good for white bread tastes
yummy we get a wheat bread like this
well you get more vitamin some more
nutritionist more everything then you
would if you bought a white bread which
is blah it's nothing and taking
everything out many states don't even
require enrichment for some flour
products the nutritional loss from
snacks pastries and donuts may be almost
total
[Music]
rice is another one of the grains from
which we manage to remove most of the
nutritious elements by taking off the
outer layers enriched white rice has had
several vitamins and iron restored but
brown rice whole grain rice that has not
been milled has all the original
nutrients the rice which advertisers
urges to eat is even less nutritious
than white rice after making instant
rice food companies attempt to make up
for the loss of nutrients by dusting the
grains with the vitamin powder such
highly processed foods are increasingly
replacing more nutritious foods in our
diet yeah I like thick like safe like
him like all these Hamburger Helper
things and Pete rice a roni and all that
tastes good and I can just fix it real
fast without having to to worry when I
get home from work what am I going to do
it just cooks up for five minutes I feed
it to everybody and that's it we usually
buy stuff that tastes good and stuff we
like to taste up and I think that it in
the long run there probably works out
alright it's all food isn't it because
of possible long-term consequences to
our health I think the more we hang on
to fairly unprocessed foods and the less
we let our food supply be invaded by
over processed foods the better it would
be for us
not only good for you but fantastically
delicious it's going to be great to eat
and that's the thing about Whole Grains
is that they're always not only much
much better for you than grains that are
tampered with but always without
exception much more delicious so what
you know what working me saying I
thought you needed vegetable oil sugar
sodium caseinate
sorbets ah what is all this stuff sodium
sterile 2 lakh too late laughs too late
light sodium caseinate mono and
diglycerides dipotassium phosphate sorry
along with the shift in the last 20
years two highly refined and processed
foods there has been an enormous
increase in the use of food additives a
typical instant mashed potato package
has potatoes but also these ingredients
a breakfast cake has sugar flour water
and shortening but also a packaged salad
dressing has all these ingredients
there dies buffers bleaches emulsifiers
preservatives flavors moisturizers and
so forth
whipped cream doesn't have milking in or
anything about what Pierce will set
milking it one reason companies like to
use these additives is because it helps
sales and profits using preservatives
multipliers and stabilizers food
manufacturers can concoct completely new
products like pudding cups
BHA and BHT are added to potato chips so
packages can sit on the shelf for three
months without going stale artificial
flavors are used in ice cream because
they're much cheaper than natural
flavors caramel coloring makes white
bread look like whole wheat bread egg
bread is dyed yellow to make it look
rich in eggs and a frozen breakfast
drink imitates real orange juice with
the aid of an orange dye it's all
imitation of the real thing space and
there's nothing you know this is this is
beautiful finally is the real thing
[Music]
there is controversy over the use of
some additives however because they are
potentially dangerous to our help it's
not necessarily the case that additives
are always bad that certainly isn't true
in many additives serve useful purposes
for instance the addition of vitamin D
to milk is very useful
adding iodine to salt has been very
useful in preventing guider however we
have to be very careful about additives
because if it turns out that any one
additive turns out to be very dangerous
that could mean harm for a tremendous
number of people and down through the
years many additives have been found to
be dangerous and most of these have been
artificial colorings so I think if
there's any any worry we should be
worrying about artificial colorings
they've been found to cause allergic
reactions cancer in animals and damage
of several internal organs like liver
and heart in animals one controversial
food dye that was once widely used is
red number two it was the most common of
all food dyes all of us consumed it yet
it has now been banned because it was
found to be dangerous to our health
other red dyes have been substituted for
it
hundreds of foods are colored with red
dyes the dyes make them look good they
help sales
[Music]
there are other additives which are also
controversial you look on the label of
Bologna salami
in small print you'll find the word
sodium nitrite this is one of the
additives to stay away from sodium
nitrite itself isn't so dangerous the
problem arises when sodium nitrite
reacts with other chemicals either in
the foods or in our stomach to create
nitrosamine in tiny amounts of
nitrosamine have been found to cause
cancer in animals food processors say
sodium nitrite is needed for curing meat
and to prevent botulism bacteria from
growing however often it's used simply
to give meats a bright pinkish color to
increase their sales appeal many
scientists and others think it should be
banned for this purpose one place where
it is definitely unnecessary is in baby
food a few years ago another additive
monosodium glutamate MSG was widely used
in baby foods the purpose was to
increase sales by making the food more
tasty to mothers when doubts arose about
the safety of MSG for babies the
manufacturers fought against removing
eventually they were forced to there was
no need for it to have been there in the
first place
today each of us takes in an average of
five pounds of additives a year some
clearly served no legitimate need and
should be eliminated from our food we
need to be very careful in I think
preventing the indefinite multiplication
of additives in our food supply we have
more than 2,000 now on the other hand to
them them all indiscriminately is to be
ignorant of the fact that in some cases
they increase rather than decrease the
safety of the food supply still another
change in our eating habits is the high
percentage of sugar in our diet by
eating a lot of sugar we invite tooth
decay and other health problems yet many
of us have a sweet tooth and food
processors are happy to encourage it now
I don't think people do realize how much
sugar they have in a diet because
there's so much sugar in hidden in foods
as something simple as ketchup and
tomato sauce there's a sugar in soup and
sugar and dust cottages some of our
cured meats have sugar in them we eat
about a hundred and fourteen pounds of
sugar a year per person the largest
amount of sugar used is the leaf in
beverages
a 12 ounce bottle of America's favorite
soft drink has seven eight nine
teaspoons of sugar Americans are on a
sugar drink bench we annually consume
more sugar drinks than milk and fruit
juices combined peaches are a good
dessert but when they are packed in a
heavy syrup you get four teaspoons of
sugar per serving in many cases we have
substituted sugar based products for
more nutritious ones artificially
colored and flavored breakfast drinks
have not only more sugar but fewer
vitamins and none of the minerals that
real fruit juices have ingredients and
food are listed in order by weight if
sugar is first it means it's the largest
item in the food
you
some breakfast cereals are almost 50%
sugar well I like bricks and chocolate
and shadows a little berries yeah I like
blueberries there's in the fruit but
sweet they make you hairy Bruno's high
that fruity pebbles and fruit loop so
you can see the sugar ones always seem
to win out Fox I got super sugar Griffin
you can't it is jelly
yummy for your tummy Frankenberry has a
strawberry sweet highly advertised very
tasty the kids love her notice five
because like it could see it advertised
on TV and it's a circle that's been very
difficult for us to break and as
nutritionist in home economists we talk
about trying to improve our food supply
and trying to improve our food by and
yet we have tremendous forces from my
advertising media to buy these products
Sugar Smacks food advertising as
considerable means about one and a half
billion dollars on media about three
billion dollars total it says a very
different function from advertising in
general in general advertising tends to
increase consumption of certain goods
and then shift preference to certain
brands in the case of food however the
total amount of food you're going to eat
is independent of the amount of
advertising you see all advertising does
is shift your food supply for your food
intake from one type of food to another
we can think of foods in four different
groups with nutrition declining from
group to group and the first group would
be veg
fruits eggs milk cheese meat and whole
wheat products in the second white bread
potatoes macaroni products some of the
better breakfast cereals and soups and
the third and now nutritional value is
going down rapidly sugar-coated
breakfast cereals some snack foods cake
mixes and so forth and in the fourth
candy soft drinks and many snack foods
however if we ate these foods in
proportion to the advertising given to
them this is how much we might eat from
each group the net effect of advertising
really is to try to shift the food
preferences of Americans from the better
foods to the worst foods and I'm afraid
it's very successful at it all the data
we have on nutrient consumption by the
American people show that since 1955
there has been a real deterioration in
the food suppliers consumed and I think
advertising very responsible fine
we have a choice we can eat the factory
foods that are pushed on us by
advertising or we can save money and eat
better with more unprocessed natural
foods
[Music]